l ormai goodbyes autori di episodi
minecraft con il borse phone nazionale
tv dei ragazzi miei facciamo una roba
che avevo detto il nostro bisogno
andiamo a vedere le case della fip o del
mio cavallo per cortesia
io però che facciamo così prendiamo
tutti del nostro cavallo visto merito ce
l'hai in due la questione di una barca
esatto perché non trovavo a lasciare
dura del tuo recinto è stato il fratello
dove è casa mia da qui vieni qua devi
andare in obliquo perché io ti seguo
partiamo dalla mia casa e pene o vedere
quelle degli altri quando non ne
regalino per arancino è sì è la nostra
volta allora qua si parte con la jacuzzi
è la apprezzano molto i polli però se si
vedente rovini costantemente sbalzato in
alto è quella da posto facendo niente
salta lui ma non è come la jacuzzi
normale non ti fanno saltare negli acuti
no non saprei fatica a fare ginnastica
poi da qui si entra si può vincere anche
alla destra abbiamo la stalla di appunto
è il mio bellissimo e super incredibile
garibaldi che va al di là di questo pari
al meno del sì ma che cosa hai cosa per
legarlo scusami ma la corda lavori in
corso
chi vorrà dire che garibaldini sia più
veloce sia saltare più di fernando
facciamo commenti vi creeps ma infatti
doveva dare anche il voto da 1 a 10 a
tutte le tradizioni e allora iniziamo
dalla tua poker la tua se vi fate un
posto da remoto delle truppe essendo la
prima è difficile perché
non smettono di paragone con le altre
vedi ti faccio con la mia no allora la
tua è veramente una signora a casa per
me un 9
ok mi piace allora pagliuca sarebbe la
faccia mi sono bloccato perché lui sa ha
un 20 per players se tu sia giusto
costante non esci più è vero poi si
continua a salire direttamente bella è
il libro e dire che è molto molto bella
complimenti bella faccia in piedi da
casa per tutti è veramente una bella a
casa originale piccato non premio troppo
il design perché va a livello di
originalità questa forse nessuno perché
troppo spesso per natural c'è proprio i
rami fanno la casa quindi bella
permettere bella bella faccia per
vederlo non bastava una volta dice
nessuno ma cosa ancora un vicolo cieco
il non sfruttato quindicenne dopo il
punteggio per ora i garra casa dello
hobbit kendall casa dell'hobby ed ora
che bella ha vere vero e bilbo beggins
che la casa alla casa di più ad andare
io darei un 8 a verona viadotto il voto
8 la vicenda questo caso di kendall che
lo hobbit
e poi c'è la parte per aspetta questo è
solo una parte della casa aspetta che
qua dentro comunque a una cosa che
geniale il march prendi nota è qua c'è
un bellissimo è una bellissima armature
impalata e mi piace quindi l'abilità e
qua c'è un letto incavato fantastico mar
ci iscriviamo pezzo molto carino e c'è
tu cosa di bello ma quali voli me la
faccia è perché era la vecchia casa di
bella faccia ma almeno togliere il
cartello un punto in meno è vero perché
proprie case partiamo da nove farli
shiva aperti dice la casa di ma che
ancora sta scritta da quant'è che non
gioca kendall si è accorto che la faccia
ha regalato una casa ma preghiera è
rimasto in mezzo a caldo di vela patti a
mezzanotte e tutto vuoto non salire poi
è piaciuto molto e ora addirittura
questo siete qua perde un sacco di mafia
allora bella fa non so se dare i voti a
bella faccia è però attendere che non ha
avuto cura dei vicini sotto secondo me è
un 9 per il per come è arredato
all'interno sopra è un 6
ma semplicemente perché non c'è niente è
comunque da fuori ma anche male però
bella faccia c'è anche un pezzo di terra
6 e media dai sette e mezzo sette e
mezzo allora a parte il fatto che la
l'accoglienza è molto figo lì perché ha
lavorato molto su la zona circostante ha
pensato proprio all'ambiente è veramente
da apprezzare questa quanti si se poi
tutto colorato bello ti sembra di
interesse ai di capita molto figo molto
figo apertura della casa che si presta
secondo me un po è migliore la tua ok
per l'utilizzo dei materiali perché si
sviluppa un po di più in alto questo
sentito campo libri in largo ma tra le
due preferisco automobilista pilota da 9
alla tua alla sua do darei un otto
però visto il fuori darei anche un 9
perché otto e mezzo da il ponte mezzo
per adesso prevediamo dentro se si conta
però è una zona interessante non ho però
fa scena è sta roba
ma sono i colori dei mesi si dimentica
di gara gara gara ha trovato una falla
della casa di guy la zona letto con la
vista sulle mucche che muoiono cioè tra
è veramente bellissimo
allora mark ai dei punti iper positivi e
dei punti iper negativi
quindi io darei
8 più fatto che siamo tornati a scuola
garibaldi preso adesso è poi guarda ora
che brutta questa cosa ora che brutta
ora le canne che una più alta di questo
grande cerchiamo non si può fare noi
siamo persone precise
allora questo è un ponte in costruzione
un'immagine che collegano a questa zona
qui che è veramente c'è to di
considerare che la casa di questa
persona è già dalle mura aia scusa per
me va bene la madonna ci stiamo a
programmi il piacere di tende ormai a
telecom era ormai mi sa che qui abbiamo
10 all apparenza perché non son resto
alieni viene c'è una casa e una scala
stupida qua fuori a che non mi piace
tutto notorio vediamo si entra solo
sguazzando non lo so però trovato che se
entrata allora c'è il fatto che è vero
ma penso che siamo noi ad aver sbagliato
però ci prendiamo ci prendiamo le nostre
responsabilità
ecco guarda alla gara gara barra c'è una
porta qui
no non si capisce tutto è un lato cento
già subito un punto via però siamo
circondati dalle mura in mezzo a un lago
di una palude e guarda che roba qua
vediamo quali della stampa e delle sedi
quali se non ti posso dare un 10 perché
non si capisce ancora capestrano si
entra fuori dalla mia ex rec casa di
stack a causa dei botti annunciati per
entrare salve già pronte zombie in
trappola questo è il figlio di shrek ma
cosa ragazzi ma richieste ma di cosa si
parla
pieno di animale è un mistico è
bellissimo se posso veramente mie sono
strano 100 bis grazie il mate 207 per i
100 bit
macché negozio di scegli me
ma cosa negozio dice io come fa davvero
come fare per un vino che per venti
smeraldi no in creative non fanno nulla
e si mettono le come a parma 2 miliardi
di villa geri finché non ricapita quello
bellissimo ma cosa fanno solo sulla
porta non la corda
sì ma lo puoi farsi e lo puoi dare un
nome alla sicilia sono dei geni
bravissimi i complimenti che idea
pazzesca hanno vissuto da quando abbiamo
percorso mai che probabilmente però
complimenti di sopra allora ho detto si
sale troppo però devo dire che la forma
e bellissima poi guarda che bello
mamma mia a imbuto veramente se queste
per tasto destro il saie è la vista
africa
bella bella bella bella complimenti
allora hai dei punti strani però quindi
non da dieci però non glielo posso
andare a casa tua o dato 9 giu nel senso
di farti capire però non si capisce
l'entrata fratello
comunque la palude mezza aperta ancora
delle palle per gli attacchi
dell'esercito si lascia metà muro
costruito si deve lavorare ancora aiuto
aumentiamo di mezzo punto la palude
perché sono stati schiattato ok mi 99
mezza allora la prossima casa ed a 10
vorrei 6 da 10 e da dire la cosa pensare
se guardi nata puoi già apprezzare
questi complimenti non sono fatti per
niente perché ma ci vedeva fare magari
talmente genuini guarda in alto c'è è
incredibile a sera 20 credibile nella
casa di marcia march si prospetta lille
architect ori al design come curtis si
dice in inglese
piller amber one vedendo il fatto che ha
fatto un veliero one piece l'ha trovato
lui bambini sono quindi già lui e e
avanti su questo ma dobbiamo ancora ci
dica all'interno perché non è la gara ci
sono pure aspettando allora lasciamo il
cavallo cui anzi lo portiamo dentro
queste cose per arare la partenza è ok
bellissima entrata splendido splendido
molto bello molto bello rientro da qui
lui è pablito lama rapito te lo regalo b
perche il sito qua ok
dopodiché abbiamo un altro a dei lama a
degli animali interni dove la fabbrica
guarda di neve queste rara questo è un
animale esotico rubato avessimo
bravissimo ricco e giustino andiamo più
di sopra che un ascensore equa che un
ascensore perché non diventi il dove non
per dire se questa cosa pazzesca
insomma che però è terra per questo è
negativo siamo dal 10 al 9 al 10 è
perché non c'è l'attenzione al dettaglio
ha ripreso quel mezzo punto
sì sì dai
e ancora ma anche gli altri dobbiamo
giudicare da noi vediamo non possiamo
pensato all ultimo piano è veramente la
scelta scena mi scusi scusi si è questo
il più bello è la madonna
il piano è una bomba a orologeria faccia
il sermone oro beh super lusso si ferro
carbone oro scritti anche i guardalinee
guarda tu sei le armature messe qua e
basso consumo ma tutti i creativi ma mai
pazzo tant'é che dobbiamo a ok sa cos'è
allora è la madonna come si scende si è
dato
ma dov'è io non lo vedo a questo è il
modo per scendere che stiamo scendendo
penso stessimo andando già in una luce
basso lo sapevo più o meno potete
credere di potere è ma dove sei stai
eccolo qua ok eccoci qui per mario
occhio
e tutto normale dai qui a novantesimo
l'equipe un bellissimo intanto questa
scusa io ho preso 37 scapoli che vede
che dovresti piantarli per arrivare
sulla verticale ormai ha capito dove
stava andando di incredibile ancora un
po più in alto
vado ecco passano le nuvole e questo
rende ancora tutto un po più chic
guardan
siamo nel punto quanti vanno abbassati
rialza visto punto e mezzo
gianni giulio va beh devo avanti la
garrucha fighissimo complimenti marciva
che la casa della madonna
allora marci diamo l'encomio per la casa
migliore che esiste senza vedere le
altre
possiamo già dire queste delle altre gli
diamo allora io gli do un 9 al 10 ma
solo per il fatto che dieci non lo puoi
dare perché la casa perfetta non esiste
sostanzialmente però anche con il fatto
che le lavorazioni clipper ci fanno
esplodere massima della v niente
l'ultima a morire ma basta ecco allora
che noia da lontano dal suo perché
sembrano di quelle casa miami pesante
però allora accogliente accoglie piccolo
ma cogliendo che è male che ti fischiano
nelle orecchie quindi c'è già una creata
a copiaco storia notare che ha copiato
del diamante china la volpina con
diamanti e copiato quindi diamo un re
data parlando di cose incantate tutte
sfruttate al minimo e charting table
senza le librerie intorno al gruppo
affronta un bellissimo ponte ma se c'è
vento caligiuri abbiamo un pozzo chi
sono fatti principali tale da farli
folli però da che possiamo scendere
scende a roma con e si capisce qual è la
strategia aperti che volete in paese uno
salica l'altro scendi devi stare nel
magma blog per sempre
ho capito male ma poi scusami la porta
la messa vicino a dove c'è cosa è quello
che non capisco
aia sto male ma veder animale per
entrare punto in meno ragazzo però casa
surrealismo bellissima la casa
sott'acqua bellissima esterna ist perché
proprio a martina the cave si vuole
garanzie che però mai quadro vicino si
vabbè vabbè bellissimo bellissima idea
guadagni un punto abbiamo tolti 8 15 e
quindi partiamo da 9 e guadagna un punto
10 22 il valore fino a 2 su 10 è nata
bene chi si è già nato trovasse un
angolino qui guardando ma vabbè basta
perché magari battere di 10 e va beh
ragazzi pazzesco incredibile male cane
per questa realtà che noi però senza
ombra di dubbio passiamo dal questo 10
almeno almeno altre tre sedi entrava che
noia però comunque direi che
direi che c'è direi che c'è quindi
mentre un bel 3 perché mentre bellissimo
volto signore io ringrazio lo staff ore
per aver partecipato questo video di mtv
vanilla minecraft creeps ragazzi ci
rivediamo ad un prossimo episodio con lo
steccone dove andrò a vedere le altre
nuove case degli altri partecipanti alla
vaniglia
beh ragazzi
[Musica]